do you think there will be a time
like a civil rights movement for robots
where
um okay forget the movement but a
discussion like the supreme court
that particular kinds of robots
you know particular kinds of systems
um deserve the same rights as humans
because they can suffer
just as humans can
all those kinds of things
well
perhaps perhaps not like imagine that
humans were
that that you could uh
you know die and be restored like you
know you could be sort of you know be 3d
reprinted and you know your brain could
be reconstructed in its finest details
our ideas of rights will change in that
case
if you can always just
there's always a backup you could always
restore maybe like the importance of
murder will go down one notch that's
right but also the uh
your your
you know desire to do dangerous things
like you know
you know doing skydiving or or you know
uh
or or you know race car driving
you know car racing or that kind of
stuff you know would probably increase
or or you know airplane aerobatics or
that kind of stuff right you know it
would be fine to do a lot of those
things or explore
you know dangerous areas and things like
that it would kind of change your
relationship so
now it's very likely that robots would
be like that because you know
they'll be
based on perhaps technology that is
somewhat similar to
today's technology and you can you can
always have a backup
so it's possible
i don't know if you like video games but
there's a there's a game called diablo
and um oh my my sons are huge fans of
this yes
and in fact they made a game that's
inspired by it
awesome
like built a game my three sons have a
game design studio between them yeah
that's awesome they came out with a game
like it just came out nice again last
year no this was last year earlier about
a year ago that's awesome but so in
diablo there's a something called
hardcore mode which if you die there's
no
you're gone right that's it and so it's
possible with ai systems
for them to be able to operate
successfully and for us to treat them in
a certain way because they have to be
integrated in human society
they have to be able to die no copies
allowed in fact copying is illegal it's
possible with humans as well like
cloning would be illegal even what's
possible because
cloning is not copying right i mean you
don't reproduce the
the mind of the person and like
experience right it's just a delay twin
so
but then it's what we were talking about
with computers that you'll be able to
copy you right you'll be able to
perfectly save pickle
the the the mind state and
it's possible that that would be illegal
because
that goes against um
that will destroy the motivations of the
system
okay so let's say you you have a
domestic robot okay
uh sometime in the future yes
and uh the domestic robot you know comes
to you kind of somewhat pre-trained you
know it can do a bunch of things yes but
it has a particular personality that
makes it slightly different from the
other robots because that makes them
more interesting and then because it's
you know it's live with you for five
years
you've you've grown some attachment to
it and vice versa and it's learned a lot
about you
or maybe it's not a hazard robot maybe
it's a maybe it's a virtual assistant
that lives in your you know augmented
reality glasses or whatever right
uh you know the horror movie type thing
right
and that system to some extent
the the
intelligence in that system
is a bit like your child or maybe your
phd student in a sense that
there's a lot of you in that in that
machine now right yeah and so
if it were
a living thing
you would do this for free if you want
right if it's your child your child can
you know then
live his or her own life and you know
the fact that they learn stuff from you
doesn't mean that you have any ownership
of it right yeah but if it's a robot
that you've trained
perhaps you have some uh
intellectual property claim about
intellectual property oh i thought you
meant like uh permanent value in the
sense this part of you is in well
there's permanent value right so you
would lose a lot if that robot were to
be destroyed and you you had no backup
you would lose a lot you know you a lot
of investment you know kind of like a
uh you know a person dying you know um
that that a friend of a friend of you
was dying or a co-worker or something
like that
but also uh you have like intellectual
property rights in the sense that that
that system is fine-tuned to your
particular existence so that's now a
very unique instantiation of that
original background model whatever it
was that arrived
and then there are issues of privacy
right because now
imagine that that robot has its own kind
of volition and decides to work from
someone else yes or kind of you know
thinks uh life with you is sort of
untenable or whatever right um
now all the other things that that
system learned from you
uh
you know how
can you like you know delete all the
personal information that that system
knows about you yeah
i mean that would be kind of an ethical
question like you know can you erase the
the mind of a of a intelligent robot
uh to protect your your privacy yeah you
can't do this with humans you can ask
them to shut up but that you don't have
complete power over them you can't erase
humans yeah it's the problem with the
relationships you know that you break up
you can't you can't erase the other
human
with robots i think it'll have to be the
same thing with robots that that risk
that
there has to be um some
risk to our interactions to truly
experience them deeply it feels like so
you have to be able to lose your robot
friend
and that robot friend to go tweeting
about how much of an you are but
then are you allowed to you know murder
the robot to protect your private
information yeah probably decides to
leave i have the situation that for
robots with with certain
like it's almost like uh regulation if
you declare your robot to be
let's call it sentient or something like
that like this this robot is designed
for human interaction then you're not
allowed to murder these robots it's the
same as murdering other humans well but
what about you do a backup of the robot
did you preserve on the on on a hard
drive or the equivalent in the future
that might be illegal just like it's
like an entire priority uh piracy is
illegal but it's your own it's your own
robot right but you can't you don't but
then but then you can wipe out
his brain so the this robot doesn't know
anything about you anymore but you still
have
technically a certain existence because
you backed it up and then there'll be
these great speeches at the supreme
court by saying oh sure you can erase
the mind of the robot just like you can
erase the mind of a human we both can
suffer there'll be some epic like obama
type character with a speech that we we
like the robots and the humans are the
same
we can both suffer we can both hope we
can both
all those all those kinds of things
raise families all that kind of stuff
it's it's uh interesting for these just
like you said emotion seems to be a
fascinatingly powerful
aspect of human human interaction human
robot interaction and if they're able to
exhibit emotions
at the end of the day that's probably
going to
have us deeply consider
human rights like what we value in
humans what we value in other animals
that's why robots and ai is great it
makes us ask really good questions
questions yeah
you